hey what's up guys my name is Hoshino
and welcome to episode 34 of 3d game
programming in Java oh I feel so good to
say that because I haven't said that in
over a month okay so we're back I hope
you guys have been enjoying the morning
coffee series by the way because that is
taking a ridiculous amount of time to
make I don't know how I'm gonna be able
to keep it daily but I'm gonna try my
best
especially over this next week trying
getting upset out every day so you guys
should see an episode out every day
except for Sunday because Sunday is 3d
game programming in Java day or actually
I've sort of renamed it to 3d game
programming okay alright so today I've
decided to do a few things today today I
wanna I want to spend it more on um I
want to sort of orient this series more
towards actually talking about what I'm
doing then getting a bunch of code down
and the thing is it's really hard to do
that because when you're making a 3d
game there's a lot of processes you have
both you know in your mind while you're
doing it and also you know in terms of
code so it's it's it's kind of hard to
try and make a bunch of you know twenty
minutes thirty minutes whatever 50
minute one hour long episodes where I
write I don't know maybe about 100 lines
of code each because at that rate you
know it would take a few years to make a
3d game like this not even like this
though because this is a I might talk a
bit about this kind of 3d game because
you guys might have realized you know
this isn't exactly this isn't this isn't
really a 3d game right this is just it's
just a it's essentially a 2-d game with
a 3d looking perspective because
technically technically if you check out
you know the definition of 3d in
computer graphics this is not really it
because this is just a ray casting
engine right so there's a few things
there's right tracing don't don't get
confuse with the right racing right
tracing is more of a 3d rendering
technique that it's kind of slower so
it's not really using games but ray
casting is
the name of this engine and I don't I
guess I should probably explain that
earlier but you know this is sort of
orange head of the beginners I guess and
you know a beginners gonna be like oh
cool ray casting engine yeah right now I
know what it's called but I don't know
anything about it but yeah so this is
the same type of engine that was used
for dungeon crawlers I guess like
Wolfenstein 3d and also doom the first
doom game that's um it's pretty much
this engine so ya I've sort of expanded
it a bit by by by making the ceiling 2
blocks high instead of one I didn't
thought that I'd played around with that
for you know for experimental purposes
this time is really dull jury actually I
want to do a few things today the main
thing I want to do today is entities
though you might have seen it by the
title so as I said you know I wanted I
wanna start taking a slower I want to
start I'm you know I guess my year 12 my
final exams for the school are gonna
come up in November and I'll probably
spend the entire tour October's before
November I've done yep
yes so I probably spend the entire
October studying for them because you
know these are my final exams basically
my my future will depend on what mark I
get in those exams you know as well as
throughout this year but about you know
60 to 70% of the mark is gonna come from
those exams so it's very important for
me to to do that which is why I do want
to take it slow I don't want to get into
too much we've done we've basically done
I guess you'd call it boilerplate code
and boilerplate code is just um it's
coded get basically gets repeated for
whatever the hell game you're making or
whatever whatever you know application
you're making so something like you know
setting up within high setting setting
up a screen class or you know this case
around the class you know setting up the
timer
and yeah I think I might redo the timer
actually I don't know if I'll do that
right now I just I don't like the way
that is currently handled so yeah
okay we're gonna do entities today about
I guess is a little bonus I'm gonna read
it the timer first so let's get rid of
ticks a lot of you guys have been
complaining that I've been using ticked
tick is essentially update all right so
we could rename it to update it's the
same thing it's it's a bit of a
convention to use taken game programming
it's um I don't know you'll see it a lot
so be mindful tick as the same as update
alright ai-ai-ai-aight right both ways
I've actually sort of leaned into
running up to add one out but um yeah so
let's list all of this let's tick count
is basically update so let's just make a
new integer we'll call it updates and
we'll set it equal to zero alright and
instead of having a boolean for this
let's get rid of this let's render we
should be rendering as fast as we can
so let's actually okay so the purpose of
this code obviously is to basically say
that yeah whatever whatever is here
let's have it happen 60 times right and
I didn't say that right I meant let's
have that let's I guess modular 260 so
in other words once every 60 ticks we're
gonna do whatever's in in here once
every 60 updates which essentially
results into a second because we're
supposed to be updating the game at
sixty times a second right there's a big
difference between frames and updates a
huge difference because you want to
always you wanna you want to basically
keep the updates static and not not Java
static not um not not Java static you
want to keep the update static is in you
know that they don't change
so I guess to illustrate this in a
different point of view excuse me for my
voice as well I'm I'm a bit sick right
now it's winter in Australia and it's
cold anyway um yeah so to illustrate
this in a different way I think I think
of this alright my computer right now is
it's it's still considered faster than
the average computer even those two and
a half years
because I built a two and a half years
ago but it's it's a very fast computer
right you might be sitting on a laptop
the difference is I might be able to you
know I guess rented this game let's just
not listen I'll talk about this game
this game is a bad example it's not very
efficient but um and I might spend an
episode making more efficient but we'll
say about that I don't think I think
there's a huge nature to be honest you
might be running a 2-d game say I might
be running a 2-d game at 500 frames per
second all right but because your
computer's not as good you might be
running it at 100 frames per second now
the problem with that is that if if we
ignore updates and just say that okay
the FPS is going to be the same as the
updates then essentially my game is
gonna change its state it's gonna update
500 times a second and yours is gonna do
it at 100 times a second now the obvious
problem there is my game will simply run
faster it'll actually physically
everything will move faster because the
computers updating you know I guess
updating the positions of AI characters
updating my updating the players
position 500 times a second whereas
yours is only doing it 100 times a
second so in one second
you know if I'm moving one pixel or
whatever one unit wants every cycle then
I'm moving a hundred units per second
you're moving I mean I'm moving 500
units per second you're moving 100 units
per second so in other words the purpose
of this timer is to make sure that we
stick and by convention it's 60 frames
per second
now why 60 frames and by frames I mean
update so I'm actually confusing you
guys aren't I
they think for example limits your frame
rate to 60 per second because you know
that that'll basically avoid you know
updating too much but it's not a problem
with this because we're not running too
fast if we were running about 500 FPS
I'd probably enforce something like 60
FPS or make the thread slave for 2
milliseconds or something every now and
then
but the point of having a timer like
this is so that we can update the game
state we can update the logic of the
game at a set amount per second so if
your computer is very fast and my
computer is very slow or vice versa or
whatever then you know our game will
look exactly the same okay that's the
case so by convention and this isn't
really by convention because if we go to
let me just duck down screen resolution
here if we go to advanced settings
you'll see that the refresh rate is
mine's actually at 59 has probably
should be at 60 but a 60s 60 Hertz
monitor I'm not gonna apply it right now
just in case it screws up my screen
recording it should be 60 there it's
pretty popular that means that we can
basically maximum we can see 60 frames
per second so our monitor will update 60
times a second right there are a bunch
of 120 Hertz monitors which apparently
really smooth you would be able to you
know in case of that I'd probably make
sure make that like 120 or so but um
because our monitors not capable of I
guess updating more than 60 times a
second you know you might as well limit
the framerate to 60 but um I guess I
guess it's fun to see how fast how
efficient your engine is so people don't
really do that that much but anyway by
by convention and by point it's good to
limit your updates per second to 60 fps
leave that usually unlimited again if
you're running you wanna if I'm not
gonna go into the whole I don't know I
don't know if you guys like this new
format that I'm trying out where I just
spend time explaining stuff like this
but I think you will this is kind of
turning me in tomorrow for podcasters
now it's probably stuff okay so let's
just wipe out this card donate that
donate that donate this and
don't need this and current I'm past
time oh my god so we're dealing with
nano time here which is nice but on the
other hand it means that we have to
convert nanoseconds to milliseconds for
the purpose of a timer so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 which is 1 billion and we want to
divide that by 60 all right because we
want our FPS to be limited by we want
our updates to be limited at 60 if we
wanted our updates that one ought not
120 we'd put that to 120 and this point
zero at the ends if you you might be
wondering why you need point zero and
why not just this one of the reasons is
that if we put a point zero we're
basically telling Java to handle this as
a double else we're just telling it to
handle it as an integer which means that
1 1 1 billion divided by 60 you know I
don't know what that equals but I can
find out that's gonna be this if we if
we divided it if we if we don't have the
point 0 here like we do now it's not
going to give you that it's gonna cut
this off and because Java rounds down
I'm pretty sure it's gonna give you that
number without this precision and we
didn't want the precision because we
want to be as precise as possible
Hellscream else
hence rather hence we need to put the
point 0 at the end all right anything
else made probably Delta and so that
equal to 0 ok so essentially I'm just
gonna in fact I'm just gonna let's put
let's push up request for Justin to heal
whoa is it really in there shouldn't
have been in water in the running loop
ok so what we want to do is we got the
current time what we want to do now is
we want to add to Delta the difference
between the current time and the last
time the previous time
I think that's right yeah yeah and then
we want to divide it by nanoseconds so
divide about by hour
no no seconds conversion into
milliseconds okay and we want to set
current time rather we want to set
previous time equal to current time okay
so now we want to say that if Delta is
greater than or equal to one which
should happen 60 times a second let's
just first of all subtract and Delta and
then let's increase our updates and
let's tick okay
there we go and in between that we
should render so let's grab rendering
frames that should be here and then
while while system the current time
milliseconds - previous time is greater
than 1000 which will be once a second we
want to do all this stuff so yeah and we
also want to make sure that updates
equals zero so that we reset that okay
we haven't used this it's alright it's
the same as Delta
unprocess seconds as identical to Delta
okay yeah okay so that's the new timer
that should work let's just run it and
we'll see what we get
all right well with chilling at zero
frames per second right now but our game
is running some idli and it's not
updating that so if something is wrong
oh whoops my bad okay previous time
let's make a long yes with a long hold
timer we'll set that equal to system
dock current time milliseconds and we'll
make sure that we're doing this and we
need to add one second to timer just
like that so let's see if this worked
yeah okay I did so now it's something
else I'm wearing at 40 FPS which is
pretty accurate actually I think we are
owning a 40 FPS which isn't good
let's don't anything to update here
though so updates plus updates or UPS
updates per second plus range okay so
they should be identical in this case
which they are okay so this is gone this
is always gonna try to be since these
bad example be killers west so let's
just lower the resolution just for the
purpose of this 280 by 60 that's tiny no
we've got the whole configuration thing
going on don't we so long since we made
this Eddie by 60 I didn't even finish
this today okay let's play okay so you
can see that we're running at 60 frames
per second and is actually doing it
twice I don't know why but um you can
see that we're running at 60 updates per
second so that's limited to 60 however
our fps is much higher so yeah it's not
pointed this existing as now let's just
make sure that we're right on the Best
Exotic okay sorry excuse me
yeah okay we're back why is it doing
that twice did I know I don't know
what's going on yeah that's fine it
seems to work
okay so now let's move on to the main
aspect of this episode seventeen minutes
in I'll give you guys a nice chilled
relaxed a long episode because hasn't
been one for like a month also actually
when was the last episode of 3d game
programming
Annette JAMA let's say June 10th Wow
really been like two months yeah it's
been wow it's been like two months since
last episode I'm sorry okay huh yeah III
private 'add the livestream by the way
from yesterday because it's completely
screwed up but this guy just sent me a
comment saying that he's still watching
it oh and he's got the troll face as
well no I'm gonna have to show you this
is kind of funny
hang on so this wise guy over here is
still watching the livestream and he's
got a little troll face so yeah it's
pretty it's pretty accurate anyway um
let's get back into this sore entities
yeah that's right okay so at the moment
let's just I hate this I this view I
hate this little view the package
Explorer seems to show like all the
folders not as subfolders so in other
words this should be a subfolder of this
but it's not this just showing all of
them there's another perspective called
navigator which shows you everything in
folders like it should be so like this
and I I just find it a lot easier to
navigate so let's go into we don't even
have yep sure okay let's make a new file
or class rather we can we could make a
new file doesn't actually matter call it
entity
dot Java just makes gives you a nice
clean I don't usually make them as files
because I'm it's there's no point
sorry mine front and let's put it into
entity so let's make a new folder called
entity that's not spelled right isn't
rename and and oh I just felt right
damn I'm paranoid today uh-hum okay so
wait so now we've got an entity class
now a lot of people arm are always
confused by the aspect of I guess you
know subclasses or in other words
classes that extend other classes and I
I think that a good way to explain it is
that it's a template
right so we've got an entity class that
we've made right here right it will
never be instantiated okay it will never
in fact we should probably make a
construct it would be it would be good
programming practice to make a private
constructor just like that
because that would just ensure that if
we were to try and make you know entity
a equals new entity then it's not gonna
let us because because it's not visible
so that would be good programming
practice let's just get rid of that
import and it's gone ctrl shift or
organizes your inputs by the way so yeah
I guess that's a good way to do that
quick simple way to make sure that we
never actually instantiate entity again
with the morning coffee episode one on
um on uh visibility modifiers it's it's
more useful to use visibility modifiers
like that if you're working in a group
or in like a company or whatever and
you're like you know you're constantly
like sharing your code with each other
you're constantly sending you know the
other guy your code and being like okay
do this for me oh you know you've got a
hang on I'm noticing a pattern here this
always stays at 22 22 22 22 I think that
there's a I'm gonna spend my time doing
that now they're actually getting
distracted anyway
so I guess that's more anything but you
know if you send someone your code and
they're like okay how is it structured
in the entity class when he sees this
he'll be like alright well there's no
way that this guy wants me to actually
make a new entity okay if I need to make
a new entity I'm not gonna use the
entity class to do that I'm gonna use a
subclass of entity to do that so yeah I
guess think think of this is a template
right so what do you want to do you
wanna um in fact you could call this
protected actually as well but I'm just
gonna call private until I need to call
protected if I need to call protected
but um
again template okay what do I need to
have in the entity class right every
every entity that I make whether it be
the player a mob other players of its
multiplayer whatever they all have a
know colors I guess a set of properties
that is applicable to every single
entity in the game right and those
entity those properties instead of
having to copy and paste them for every
single entity
I can just make like a template or like
you know or in a superclass in this case
but I could just make like a reference
of those variables so that whenever I
make new entities whether it be you know
at the player or whatever they're gonna
have these these variables already
assigned to them so let's make a few
protected variables so X&Y first of all
they're gonna be the X&Y location on the
map I'm gonna call it X and Zed just
because Y is vertical so I don't really
want to mess with that
what other things away I'm just doing
this on the fly by the way I don't
you've had I didn't even have any notes
in front of me so I might be coming back
to this class and adding more of this
stuff because I don't know what I'm
doing okay what else we need I like to
have a protected Boleyn
called removed so in other words if we
run the public method the public in
facts yeah the public method public void
remove then it will set removed equal to
true and basically what this will do is
when we talk about array lists in the
future we can be able to say that if
removed equals true then removed the
entity from the ArrayList so in other
words destroy it stop updating it and
stop rendering it and you will see that
in the future okay that's gonna be it
for now cuz I can't think of anything
else I don't want to put sprite into
here how how leaf and managing sprites
I'm sorry by the way it's been 2 months
since I've opened up this project so I
have no idea what the structure is I've
forgotten everything
so yeah just bear with me through that
but um we're just hand we're just
handling a single a single arm sprite
shade only and was yeah ok and we're
setting hang on
oh.okay was statically setting oh why
are we doing about I yeah uh I probably
wouldn't do that now if I was to rewrite
this game I'd probably do it completely
differently
sure I am yeah that works too I guess
anyway so let's make a few more things
let's just make a mob class so let's go
to class
make a new package for it and we'll call
it mob and mob will extend entity okay
so let's import entity make sure you
bought the comm dot the my front one not
the the Java the Java X the job ax
whatever the hell was there yeah we're
gonna have to have a constructor for
this let's just call this protected so
that we don't we get rid of that era
okay um let's see okay so a mob is gonna
basically because we it works to any
entity right x and y and removed are
already in here so that's all fine but
you know basically now we're saying what
do we want all mobs to have in common
that and that all entities don't so in
other words if we have like a I don't
know a rock we don't want the rock to be
able to move exactly do we we do want
entities to be able to move so what we
need is a move method right move method
so the amount is gonna move in X and the
amount of this kind of move in Y and
this method is gonna basically move the
player or whatever in fact let's just
make a player class at the moment we've
called a controller I believe yeah okay
let's just move to controller class to
mob and let's change the package
declaration and let's rename this so
control one thing old shift our to
refactor it so that we don't need to
copy and paste a name
that's alright
and in for our our stuff okay let's just
check that this still works and we've
got an arrow somewhere
oh crap we've got a lot of errors what's
the problem with this oh it's in a
different package damn it's gonna take a
while I'll maybe not seven arrows zero
errors yay oh yeah let's check that we
can still move yeah okay we can okay so
at the moment we're using an interesting
way to move let's just make sure that
player extends mob and now what we want
to do is we want to fix up a bunch of
this stuff so first thing we don't need
is these two variables and also I don't
want to be able to immediately um okay
so Zetas in public let's make this
public okay
I don't want to be able to I don't want
to manipulate I guess the X values
immediately but rather I want to UM III
want to call a move method and I guess
modify them separately so you'll see
what I mean in a second so what I want
to do is in here first of all okay a few
things
they cross my mind when I think of now
this is interesting well this 43 updates
42 owner don't swear I saw something
different there anyway first thing that
first thing we crosses my mind when I
think this is collision detection
immediately cross in my mind what I
think of moving and the reason is that
if we if we handle collision detection
in a fairly efficient way it will
completely crash if we try and slide
against the wall so in other words when
we crash into a wall we don't want to
you know move backwards being the only
option we sort of want to be able to
slide across it this is sort of more
applicable for 2d games but I think
it'll work for 3d as well and basically
what we want to do is say that if if
we're if and the way we can fix this is
if we're moving so in other words if 0
ok this is it gonna be negative 1 or
positive 1 right and in fact it's gonna
be everything in between because this is
3d but the point is zero means that
we're not moving at all so in other
words if both of them are not zero so in
other words let's make sure everything
is called set so if we're moving in both
directions if we've got like W and D
press down if we're moving both left and
forward then let's handle them
individually by just moving this and
then just moving that and then make sure
we return so what that's gonna do is
it's gonna return our method and then
it's kind of process it twice but in a
much better way so basically what we
want to do is just X plus equals XA and
said plus equals said a okay and we'll
have to figure out rotation and
everything in second again so let's get
rid of this
okay so if we move forward we want to XA
equals 0 and z equals zero so every time
we go through this take method this
update method we're gonna set them back
to zero again so if we move forward we
want that a to be plus plus so in other
words za will become 1 and remember it
won't become anything greater than 1
because it will be reset to zero before
it does it again so if we go back we
want to - - we might have to flip this
control as well I'm just doing this on
the fly again XA plus minus minus and
right will be XA plus plus okay so a
rotation left and right that's cool but
yeah this could be a problem actually
let's hope it was not gonna be there so
after rotation yeah that's actually
really interesting because I don't know
how this is gonna pan out okay let's
just see let's just see how this works
let's just move like that and we will
actually need to know the rotation value
keep writing Y a instead of set a let's
get rid of this it was just the mouse
stuff so let's go into move and let's
make sure that we wrought for rotation
okay so what we need to do basically is
set I guess a new X I call them an X and
basically we need to use vectors here to
make sure that we are just a bit of
water we need to use vectors here to
make sure that we're going the right way
so wanna bust open paint on that so that
I can show you guys what I meant okay
so we're going this way for example
we're not going straight or whatever
we're going at that angle and this angle
let's just say it's 40 degrees that is
crap
I shouldn't even try should just use
this you know 40 40 degrees essentially
what with what we want to do is we want
to figure out how much we need to move
up and how much we need to move right so
if we're facing this direction if we're
facing this direction we need to figure
out the up value and the right value
that we need to move so the the the up
value will technically be Zen because
this is 3d and this will be X we need to
figure out the Zed and the x value did
the amount of the Zed and the x value
that we need to move every every update
basically so in other words this might
be something like 0.8 this might be
something like I don't know 1.0 because
obviously we're going actually
technically if it's 40 degrees it'd be
the other way around but my point is
well what is it supposed to be this is
really my writing 0.8 holy crap
anyway uh-hum I should just use like a
tablet or something I am one of those
graphics tablets the drawing things with
a pen anyway so anyway so to work this
out what we need to do is use a very
complex algorithm that we've already
used before to figure out this so in
other words what I'm going to do is we
need to X plus equal
and X so an X being you know this value
or this value depending that's present
though so we need to add it to that okay
so double it and X is gonna equal let me
to do it with rotation so that's hmm
okay hang on and X is gonna be cosine
because cosine is to do with X and
scientists do with Y of the rotation
except we'll need to figure something
out here as well that'll probably be too
fast let's just do the same thing for
whoops for y okay
now we're also going to have to multiply
this by no just called as said by za so
in other words if said a equals zero
it's gonna give you zero and dessert
it's not gonna move at all
which is actually kind of wrong but
we'll figure something out in a second
because the other thing is we need to
add sorry this should be sine we need to
add oops we need to add this to the
equation and subtract it from this I
think that's right okay so that should
give us the right thing and then we can
multiply both by whatever modifier we
want if it's going too slow or fast
let's make these double I hope that
nothing crashes good and just gonna
really be interesting if it works okay
so let's get rid of this yeah so you can
see that basically it's the same code
that I just wrote except I think I did
it wrong because where are we mob
because this should be sign and this
should be cosine
all right I guess we'll see yeah okay
okay let's check it out okay so it works
and not exactly so you can see how that
does not exactly work for rotation but
main movement does work and we are very
fast so I might slow that down okay
so now let's figure out the problem with
with this I feel so weird doing a story
all by the way because I haven't done
one in two months so just give me a
break just for this episode so
something's wrong something's not adding
up with the rotation I'm not sure what
it was but we shouldn't mean so quick to
delete
maybe protection a nod to final thing is
it's things bugging me is that it is
sort of working isn't it forward
45 degrees like say it's not it's not
completely stupid although I can't get
it to me that way
yeah that's odd
okay let's come back here and see if we
can maybe I was right in the first place
not really not okay
ha make sure that everything's right
here
the next said whoops what I just type in
placeholder we want to see the render 3d
gloss make sure everything is right here
and that does in fact occur - oh yeah
let's see our rotations set
that's right everything off I think ha
okay let's um let's let's deconstruct
this and make sure that we're doing
everything right first of all the wall
rotation - plus a full rotation yes for
sure so that when we rotate oh yeah
maybe not
that makes it nothing nice and smooth
okay so it's working I think until 90
degrees yeah okay let's figure this out
let's go into the move method and let's
check out what the value of rotation is
right now so it's 25 is 26 oh that's
weird
yes clearly not working because I can't
fit a problem
so you just keep turning basically I
think it's in radians though it should
be in radians shouldn't the whole thing
should be in radians not degrees so 1.5
this should be 1.5 this should be 0 and
hang on if it's in radians so it's 3
radians for doesn't work here that does
it but um it's 3 radians for an int up
for a half a circle that's wrong that
can't be right it's supposed to be oh no
that's right that is right it is in
radians and it is right because pi is
3.14 and that's what this is basically 3
1 6 okay that is right that's good so
what is giving us the correct rotation
value that's for sure but Oh first of
all it's moving us every second let's
make sure that it only moves us if XA
doesn't equal 0 or make sure you don't
put and/or za za doesn't equal 0 let's
um actually let's quickly go into window
preferences let's go into Java right
thank you Java code style formatter
edit this edit this and go into control
statements and keep simple if on one
line so that we when we hit control
shift f it formats it nicely like that
because it is just a simple if statement
with just one line so we might as well
keep it like that ok so now we shouldn't
be yet now we should only update it as
you can see when we move
okay so then something's wrong with this
math and let's not print a thing because
we know it works
so X a x equals so you know what's 1 x
equals that Plus how is this wrong I
don't get it
this is negative right that's not gonna
watch nope oh this is boggling my mind
right now cuz I don't know what I've
done wrong
hang on that why is this card here it's
interfering with oh my god did you just
say that oh god I want to cut the loss
fit of me yeah this is stupid
see this is what I'm talking about this
is why you should add comments into your
card that just cost me like 20 minutes
okay now it's freaking walks beautifully
like should have from the very beginning
scary this crap unbelievable yeah so the
reason that didn't work if you didn't
see it very clearly now we're freakin
sway irritation speeds a bit fast but
I'm part from that a bit slower 0.3
might be nice
oops okay let's just leave it at live
let's just leave it at that
all right so you might have noticed the
problem there was that we were also
adding an incorrect value to the thing
we were also doing this as well which
was interfering with everything because
it was causing this to happen or in
other words he basically just ruined
everything so and I didn't realize that
card was there because I forgotten I'd
forgotten how I'd made moving work in
this game so that that sucks all right
so now we've got entity entities right
we've got our entities working out
correctly we've got a lot of move method
for our lovely lovely mobs and we've
also got our base entity method which
contains a few different values what I
want to do now quickly before I go is
set up a few things in level okay so at
the moment level has an array of blocks
which had this stuff right but what I
want also to happen is public void
render or more like update so I want
this card right here
that's the constructor isn't it huge
let's um
let's quickly get this crap out of the
way generates level walked out into
there okay update that's basically what
we want to do is we want to update our
entities so in the beginning of this
whole thing in our display class we've
got a player where's our player variable
now yeah I could be wrong because I
haven't actually don't remember how this
works
oh it's in our game class isn't it yeah
so got a we basically got this going on
here
so we're updating the player we're
updating everything throughout
throughout here which is cool but we we
want to be able to update if we have
like 100 plays in the game or whatever 1
100 mobs in the game just running around
we don't want to have to create new
instances of each of them we don't want
to have to say alright let's make
another player called player 2 and now
what we're gonna have to do is we're
gonna actually have to create then you
player and we're gonna have to also you
know tick the new player right and you
can imagine that if we've got like a
thousand of them or whatever then we'll
have this huge thing here that is just
crap and we don't need so the solution
to that is to use an ArrayList now what
is an ArrayList we've never used an
ArrayList before in this series and a
bunch of you are probably wondering what
an ArrayList is and I will answer that
in a minute
maybe I should save it for next episode
actually yeah now although with this
episode okay sorry
an ArrayList is basically like an array
hence the name right so what we could do
you guys might say is let's just make an
array list of players right called
players and then what we'll do is we'll
add as many as we need to that now
that's cool but what if we want a
specific what what if the amount of
players changes right once the player is
dead once we kill another mob on our
screen we want to remove it from that
array to save memory usage we want to
get it out there because we don't we
don't we don't want to be updating it we
don't want to be rendering it it's gone
it's dead let's get rid of it let's call
the removed method and remove it from
the array now you can't do that with
entity we can't do that with an array
okay because it's not dynamic the size
of the array the index of all the items
in the array that's fixed once you set
that it's done well what we need to do
so like with blocks right we can't
change which block is aware while we're
running the game because it's an array
and we've set it up once now an array
list that is like a dynamic array okay
there's no such thing as a right index
out of bounds because the the bounds of
the array or whatever as much as we need
basically if we can keep adding I don't
know a million mobs to the map and it'll
still be fine so apart from you know
all the other crap like memory usage and
mostly memory usage actually and
probably processes and processing at a
time as well so what we want to do here
is we want to set up a new ArrayList
which will hold all that all our
entities so right all we need to do is
go private list entity now first thing
going to ask is what are these fancy
less-than and greater-than zones
enclosing the word entity now this is
basically all this is doing is it saying
that this list is going to contain a
type of object it's going to contain
entity objects and that's it we can't
add
for example a level object to this right
we we can't just decide to add a level
to it okay it needs to be if we set
entity as basically the contents of this
list it has to be it can only contain
entities this list can only contain
entities will call it entities since
I've been saying that word for past hour
and its name a upset and we'll set that
equal to new ArrayList and again entity
right and then you'll have your things
as usual now it's important so make sure
you import the one that is any util not
or not a WD util and obviously entity is
our interesting that's it okay swipe so
now we've got an ArrayList now we've got
an array list of entities well what we
want to do now is public void add entity
and entity a so in other words we want a
method to add a new entity into the
level so all we need to do here is say
that entities dot add a right so it's
gonna add whatever entities in the
parameters to a little list now we need
to update every single entity now the
reason I'm not making a random method is
because we're not actually rendering the
player the players like just a camera
it's not actually being ready at the
moment we'll probably get onto that
later but anyway so if in other words
for ni equals zero we're gonna make a
full loop to render all the entities
indeed list I is less than entities dot
size it's not length in in arrays its
length in list is so it's sorry let me
just grab some water
in lists its size and it's also it's
also a method it's got these things I
plus plus and all we want to do is we
want to e sorry entities get now the
index is gonna be I write and we want to
update so tick or whatever now okay so
to do that we need to make the actual
update method okay so yeah okay so you
can see that I've made like a method
here that doesn't do anything that's
cool but remember if we have the exact
same method in player it will do
something because we're rendering we're
actually doing a player we'll see in a
bit in a minute what I mean
tick let's come into player and get rid
of this crap let's just rewrite the
entire tick method sorry
come with me cuts oops don't want the
last line oh there we go
paste okay so a bunch of errors that's
no problem
public player and and put handle input
and we'll make a private input handler
here
called input and we'll just set this dot
input equals input so all we're doing is
we're saying that when we create the
player initially we'll put an instance
of the input handler object to that and
then we'll just set this input equal to
this input so that we can use the input
handle objects' right throughout this
class so let's go into the input handler
thing and there's a lot of crap here
let's make a bunch of yeah okay let's
make a bunch of uhm mmm
go into game and just grab this and pop
it into here and we need to make an
update or a tick method and we just need
to basically set this okay let's cut
this and put it here and then bullying
forward back left right rotate left
rotate rights jump
crouch and run
okay and let's come into here and I'm
pretty sure that we've gotten yeah we do
in-game Deltek just on the game dick and
put tick and we don't need this
let's get back into a display class real
quick and game class let's move this up
well whole screen just flashed it's odd
where's game close where's my game close
okay so new player and it'll be input
and looks like we left it add this into
here and over here I'll just add input
and make sure that it is that this thing
is before it otherwise was given all
will get a null pointer exception so
we'll set it input equal to them that's
right it well we'll just add it in D
into the game get rid of that cool so a
few hours that's alright we're fixing
everything
okay sweets
what's one what a run used to be I've
got no clue make it public mmm that's
shift isn't it yeah it would be okay so
we fixed everything out let's see if it
works and it works perfectly okay sway
it so now I've got this in here now
this is gonna be the longest episode
ever isn't it no I am gonna cut like 20
minutes out of it so maybe it won't be
okay I gotta go back to watching Dexter
it's like before I've been I just
finished season one I'm Dexter yesterday
for the first time oh it's so good so
good you haven't checked our desk so
check it out second he's such a good
sure anyway um we just turn the
backlight on for my keyboard because I
can't say the case and I like seeing the
case because it's cool
and I can actually see what I'm doing
okay so what we want to do is we want to
level dot add layer okay
so that way we don't need to take the
player we only need to to take the level
did I call it up to it yeah I did not
really consistent it doesn't matter
level did update
let's call everything tick rename call
everything tick for this project
that should work so let's just say
crashed I wanna crush with a
nullpointerexception so level of Cologne
yeah hey you want to do that after you
set level equal to alright not Java a
alright okay so this should work
yeah I guess you can see the we're
updating player perfectly right now
even though we are we don't actually
technically calling the update method of
the player so in other words that is
mission accomplished and yes let's make
them map a lot smaller and next next
week on Sunday we could do one of two
things guys someone I have to actually
get you to to post so many walls let's
make walls a bit rarer right now so
let's just say 28 and maybe this 25
there we go nice ok so two possibilities
from it for episode 35 we could either
do collision detection and I know a lot
of you guys are going to like jump up
off your seats and be like Oh finally
yes we could either do collision
detection next Sunday or level design
and by level design what I mean is that
we're going to be able to go into a
program like paint.net and basically you
know draw whatever level we want and
each separate color will be a different
type of block okay so we could do that
so either level design where we'll read
the level file as being an image as a
PNG image and each different color is
going to be a different block at that
particular location so we can draw but
we can basically draw a 2d a top facing
map of the level and that will actually
be what level looks like or we could do
collision detection one of the two
options so yeah so I actually well I'm
thinking about this right now and I'm
like I don't know what's gonna win I
know you guys want collision detection
but you also want level designs so that
will do next week guaranteed one of the
two unless something very bad happens
and I won't have time or something so
yeah thanks for watching this episode of
3d game programming in Java give it a
like because it's very long and because
there hasn't been an episode in so long
so yeah and um I'll see you I'll see you
guys next week bye
[Music]